hello hello everyone and welcome back to
the road
2000 as always my name is caleb denby
and tonight
is a bittersweet night here uh coming
from the studio
because this may very well be our last
road 2000 championship tourney
that's right this could be your last
chance to become champion
of the road um i am going to be hosting
and to switch things up tonight guess
what
guess what's gonna happen you see this
button right here this big button that
says join
i'm gonna click it there you go i'm in
although i think i need to refresh my
page here because
uh something was not quite right on that
one
and so uh you're probably wondering you
know
now that caleb's playing i want to play
too how can i do that
well it turns out it's super easy first
thing you got to do
go to this page what's this page
well this is the page for our chess.com
club so you're going to want to be
clicking on that you're going to want to
be
joining our club and
from there you are good to go hello njf
hello martin muhammed uh hopefully you
can all see me and hear me okay
uh we had some tech issues uh before the
stream
but i think we are up and running and
rocking and
rolling all of those things uh so like i
was saying
first thing you got to do go to this
page that i posted in
the chat and you see uh this tournament
right here
road to 2000 live stream tourney that's
where
where you can find uh find your stuff
and actually now i'm realizing
that maybe you're not saying everything
that i
am talking about uh if i click this do
you see it
maybe you don't that's okay uh go to the
link
join our club and then join our
tournament we've got five people in
there
right now that's not enough people for
the rug 2000
uh live stream tourney we can do better
we can do better
so there you go join the tournament
that's the link directly to the
tournament you do have to be
a member of the st louis chess club team
in order to join and it's going to be a
really exciting night tonight
i'm happy i am ready to test my medal
against all of the road to 2000 faithful
students i think you guys are gonna put
up a good competition
congrats on winning the last attorney
well i won
the uh under 2300 at the chicago open
now it's time to see if i can win the
road 2000 championship
uh time is short join while you can you
have just
five minutes and 40 seconds left
to join in on the fun here
don't dilly don't dally join well you
can
and hopefully we have a great event
um so once again this is the first
edition of the road 2000
championship where i will actually be
competing
so if you want to uh try and take down
the instructor
now is potentially your only chance
of course at the chess club we are
starting to go back to more
in-person tournaments if you're local to
st louis it's great news we've got all
sorts of fun events
uh going on at the chess club and so our
virtual tournaments
are likely going to be slowing down a
little bit including
the road to 2000 live stream tourney so
this might be your last month to get in
on
all the fun action uh on chess.com here
we have tournaments almost every day and
it might not be like that for much
longer so join up
while you can alright we're up to eight
players so far uh i'm on the chess
club's account here we're rated 2 000
and are the number one seed still but
counter sparks just joined with the
nice 1800 rating to uh to give us a
run for our money here so we'll see what
we can do
um also noticing some chess club
regulars we've got mike in here
so much better than you and alex um
and this mendel person i i think i
remember mendel playing uh
playing one of the previous tournaments
and doing fairly well so look out for
that
pb diamond also definitely has played
before
and chef kez perhaps that's a new one
don't recognize it off the top of my
head mike glowdemons
also potentially new steve says you
remember you lost me once but revenge is
like sashimi
best uh best served cold so
shiver when you see me all right i'll be
on the lookout also got philip in the
chat
joining us here uh anne's
i don't know i'm ready i'm looking
forward to it does it start in three
minutes yes it does start in three
minutes
uh specifically three minutes and 33
seconds
so time is wasted turn your bit right up
really quick
just for a second um oh
it how bad is the quality bed no i can
hear you all the way but it's just like
everything
but if it rains super low
let's just keep going all right
hopefully the stream looks okay uh ben
said perhaps our bit rate is a little
bit low but we're gonna roll with it
we are gonna roll with it and uh play
this tournament
hello az once again join
the tournament if you're just joining
it's not too late you have three minutes
left
to join in we're up to nine players um
which is enough for the full seven round
event thankfully
but uh we need some strong people where
all the strong students at
with the big ratings
i know we're all on the road to 2000 but
some of us are further along than others
some of us are further along than others
i remember in one of the previous events
we actually had uh some national masters
playing
who weren't me which was very exciting
to see
that even national masters can be on the
road 2000 as well
the road back to 2000 as they say
all right up to 10 players we've got
osta
ostpo joining the tournament and just
two minutes left
two minutes left to join join while you
can um
you may have to join our st louis chess
club team first but after that
you are in business to compete
again this is your last chance
potentially to play
in a road 2000 tournament if you want to
be crowned grand champion of the road to
2000
for life now is your best chance it's
your best shot at it
grand champion for life there may not be
another chance
for you to be dethroned after tonight
minute and 30 seconds to go everybody
minute and 30 seconds
alex wishes people good luck um
of course there was one grand master in
residence in particular here at the
chess club
who would always wish everyone good
skill that was
uh that was his thing it's wishing
everyone good
skill but we're not nerds here we know
that it's better to be lucky
than good so i'm with alex on this one
good luck
to the competitors just not quite as
good
uh of luck as i have hopefully
and the tournament is about to start
we've got less than a minute
if you want to join in less than a
minute everybody
join in while you can
join while you can
all right and i think we're underway
here
in another 30 seconds up to 11 players
11 players angry bird in the tournament
now
angry bird all right
and i'm feeling a little bit nervous to
be honest it'll be pretty embarrassing
if i don't win
uh my own live stream tournament you
know uh
i i hear i think i'm willing to make the
deal if you beat
me in the events not just win a game
against me but if you get first place in
the event
uh higher placed than me i think it's
only fair
that you get to keep the class so if you
want to be the instructor of the road to
2000 you should have joined but now we
are officially
underway let's start off with d4 here
and uh these games
keep in mind are three plus zero so we
gotta
make sure we're staying ahead on the
clock here and this is exactly
what i say whenever i commentate these
things um
if you're behind on the clock it almost
doesn't matter if your position is good
depending on uh how bad your time
deficit is we've got
a dutch defense on the board in the
meanwhile and my opponent gets
a pretty early e5 in but in return i get
to play this move e4
i'm gonna kind of hope that the e5 pawn
is a little bit weak
hoping this d5 square might also be a
little bit
uncomfortable for my opponent to deal
with all right we see knight c6 by my
opponent defending e5
i'm gonna keep up the pressure here once
again gotta stay up on the clock
gotta stay up on the clock
oh and mike's in the chat saying good
luck
in the youtube chat that is okay now we
see takes here i think i'm gonna have to
take this back
don't think i have time to play takes on
f6 can't see the moves
that would be a problem if you can't see
the moves wouldn't it
uh so i'll tell you what i'm going to do
i'm going to
refresh this one here
let's see what we got
all right that should be fixed now i'm
hoping
i'm hoping that's fixed is that fixed
that looks like it's fixed all right
thank you whoever in the chat that was
telling me to fix my stream but also how
dare you
now i'm actually down on the clock i
think i see a tactic i'm just going to
play it hopefully it works
and i think it does uh this
was my trick is that i have this check
here if rook takes
play or rookie six i'm gonna play rookie
five
and then um and then we're good
and then we're good i think you can see
original position only i think you
should be
fixed now i think it should be fixed i
know we're dealing with a little bit of
delay as well
but i think we're all on the up and up
here finally
it is fixed okay good good to know good
to know okay rook f2 looks scary but i
think i might have
some tricks here pinning the queen to
the king somehow
and i think it's all working out i won a
pawn
and i'm not even behind on the clock
fixing streams on the fly
not even behind the clock c6
unfortunately didn't really stop my
threat here
and i should be winning a queen
and don't worry about what happened
before then
yeah apologies for the technical
difficulties
once again there um hopefully this is
the last week when we have all sorts of
these problems
um a little bit of behind the scenes
here at the chess club we actually
recently had to tear up the whole studio
and put it back together to uh to
you know fix something um and so we're
not quite totally put back together so
i'm still
having to put on a producer cap in some
instances
and i think everyone can agree it's just
better
when ben is in charge of everything and
i don't have to pretend i know what i'm
doing
all right in the meantime though i have
won my first round
convincingly nonetheless so now that our
game's over
why don't we take a look at the
competition here we've got
uh shelhada uh as one of the
other highest rated players and he's up
against alex alex from the chess club
so let's see what we can do here
shelhada with the black pieces and a
pretty decent position
alex rocking the bishop pair though
absolutely rocking the bishop pair yeah
good game mike
good game uh we just had some uh some
tactical difficulties
in our game while the technical
difficulties we're on but we figured it
out
and uh yeah that queen eight check
just not easy to deal with okay bishop
f6 now looks like shelhada is stepping
out of the pin
there may be some threats against this
knight on d5
although for the moment that bishop was
defended queen c4
and yeah black here seems to be trying
to make use of this knight in order to
counter the the power of this bishop but
alex has just taken pieces off the board
just taking them all and white has more
pawns than black if i'm counting
correctly
one two three to two on this side that's
a one pawn advantage
all right rook d7 now alex is getting
active and
you know i have to say shelhada by far
the raiding favorite
in this game but alex is giving him
quite a fight here quite a fight
uh who else is still playing looks like
most people are actually still playing
we had our game finish
reasonably early but shale hada is the
one to look out for here
um counter sparks definitely won their
game early and
moved to one point of one as well as
there you go now you got to hear me try
to say that
and oh what's that what's that i always
say at the top of
every one of these tournaments the
position on the board
once again is irrelevant as the players
simply have not been playing fast enough
alex down on the clock
and that matters much more than being
down on the pawns
and perhaps now we see why shell hottest
rating is higher than alex's
for the moment you just gotta move fast
it's three plus zero
it's three plus zero this is not your
grandmother's time control
this is a young person's time control
all right
uh this bishop's attacked and black
takes it
now we get a bishop trade in point four
seconds
alex just is not gonna have enough time
to finish this game
and we see shelhada coming away with the
victory here
with the victory and with that i think
all of the games have completed is that
true and it is true
on to round two let's see if i can
maintain my position at the top we're up
against l in in in hennes
no messing around in the road 2000 live
stream tournament
we're here to win we're not here to uh
play openings we don't know we're here
to play solid
and convincingly all right i am going to
play
g6 and bishop g7 go for this kind of
setup
um depending on what my opponent does i
think i'm just going to bring the bishop
out to g4 sometimes i like to put this
guy
on f5 and offer this sort of unique
little trade
but in this case i think it's simpler
and probably better to just
bring the bishop out to the natural
square i'm going to play a weird move
now
knight e8 i'm going to start heading to
d6 looking at some of these light
squares
and maybe maybe maybe i'll start pushing
maybe oh my pawn's attacked so i'm going
to defend it always defend
your pieces when they are attacked good
it's just good life rule to follow you
know what i mean
okay bishop f4 i'm not so afraid of my
opponent uh
taking my guy i'm gonna play a6 uh
prepare b5 a little bit before i play it
my opponent might play a4
but that create creates uh some more
weaknesses over here
that i could try to exploit okay queen
e3 i get the feeling my opponent is
trying to play bishop h6
i am just not a believer in the power of
bishop h6 here i don't think my king's
side is very weak at all
got a nice solid setup over there so i
am
not afraid okay i'm gonna bring the
knight into c4 now that's why we
rerouted it from f6
okay and the queen moves away and gives
up on bishop h6 so
turns out i was correct to not uh be too
concerned about that move if i
play a5 them then maybe pawn to b3 is my
opponent's idea i'm going to play rookie
8 here
the idea of bringing this bishop back
maybe aim at these dark squares a little
bit more
more thoroughly more carefully
even on the clock want to definitely
keep it that way it's always tough when
you're talking about your games
to also play your games
but that's the challenge here on the
road to 2000 tourney okay we get b3 from
the opponent i don't
think my opponent should have played
this unless they absolutely had to
because now it's going to be tough to
keep all of these squares together i can
bring my rook over to c8
and the pawn on c3 missing a defender
now the pawn on c3 also pinned to the
queen
looking a little bit tough for el
inanioso
and okay bishop e5 i think this tactic
is good i think this one works
pawn is pinned to the queen knights
defended via
x-ray through the bishop pulling out the
old x-rays here
on my opponent and we'll see
what he chooses he chooses queen back to
d1 i think though now i can continue
taking stuff
and all of the holes in the position
sort of fall
at the same time all the weaknesses
are coming apart
now i'll go queen f6 or something and
try to take this guy
maybe i'll just take it out right
it's a little bit scary having
everything on this diagonal but if i
ever get checked i can
play queen f6 or if i ever get pinned as
well
and what's more i i don't even see how i
can get checked or pinned
so not too much danger at all
rook c1 is an idea to follow up so
knight
to e2 is good enough to stop that idea
i will retreats i will retreat
now i should work on rerouting my pieces
make sure i stay safe
this knight's a little bit too loose
here for my liking so i'm going to pull
it back
bring this other knight to the nice
strong square on c4
and now i shouldn't be in too much
danger at all all my pieces are defended
i have many more pawns i also have many
more seconds
which is very very important and life is
good bring this knight to d3
defend and attack
uh take the free stuff oh save the free
stuff
play queen f6
and we'll bring in the pieces now time
to bring in the big guns that's free
rook
i'll take it that's free queen
i'll take it
threaten checkmate
that's free night
and that's the game winner winner
chicken dinner
all right let's see how the competition
is doing um shelhada looks like
they finished their game still two out
of two
corn wallace also on two out of two
let's check out this game
between scouter park counter sparks and
mendel
and counter sparks comes away with the
victory as well
and back to the tournament here looks
like almost all the games are done
maybe this game with brie tack is the
last one remaining
looks like they're both down to 10
seconds oh my gosh
and white has more rooks but black has
more pawns
and more minor pieces and more seconds
for the moment the king is running the
king is running up the board
and chef kez just simply out of time
again
the common thread here the player with
more time on the clock
is the one that is winning and there is
now a
shillesh in the chat i wonder if she
less
shalash and shelada are perhaps the same
person
all right i'm going to go with d4 here
keeping it simple
we'll develop our pieces my opponent
hasn't put a knight
onto the f6 square yet so i'm kind of
intentionally
leaving my knight here on b1 because
against this line i am just not
interested in allowing some funny
business with bishop takes c3
so i just won't develop until my
opponent does
i have plenty of other useful things to
do and i intend to do them
i'm going to bring this knife back to e1
now uh pave the way for my f
pawn to move and uh also now
uh bringing this knight to a better
square on e3
or d3 my opponent brings the knight out
in this direction and i'm not so sure
this is going to go
quite how my opponent is hoping it will
i'm going to play f4
here and because my opponent has taken
so long to develop the pieces i think
i'm going to be able
to develop rather quickly here and give
my opponent some real problems castles
is a move black might want to do but if
black does it then all this pressure
down the h file is going to suddenly
disappear
and that's why we see my opponent going
for this instead
hoping for some queen h4 funny business
am i going to allow it i could play h3
here
i could potentially play something else
i could play f5
just to increase the tension to the
maximum
and i believe that's what i'm going to
do nah
yeah nah yeah i'll play f5 we'll try and
have a little bit of fun here if queen
h4 i can still play g3
uh my queen defends the mate laterally
and
that comes with tempo as well so my
opponent is gonna have to move the queen
and then i'll have time
to capture on a square like e6
if i go here my opponent might be
intending to move e5
i could consider capturing on e6
first do i want to or not
um let's go ahead and take on e6 as well
just want to rip it open as much as
possible here and
give my opponent some problems
e5 now i can play something like knight
f4 and the d5 square is open for my
knight as well as the e6 and g6 squares
um e5 knight of four if queen h4
um hold on e5 904 there might be
knight f2 funny business but it doesn't
seem too scary queen h4 would still have
g3
and life is is good in that position
and once again my opponent's position
may be okay
but my opponent's clock is definitely
not okay definitely not
um need to make a move here my opponent
does play this move e5
and now i suppose i have a little bit of
a decision to make i can
develop my pieces or i can try
to win just outright just win right away
um honestly i think i would rather
develop my pieces here i'm going to play
knight c3 i don't really mind if my
opponent wants to take
yeah my opponent is playing for
checkmate fair enough
um i was going to originally play g3 i
suppose i still am
i'm noticing now that queen h3 might be
uh worth some more consideration than i
gave it
but it should still be fine should still
be fine i go bishop
g5 because i need to defend my rook so
if knight takes h2
i can take it and my rook isn't hanging
and now my opponent castles
shocking everyone with the legality of
the move
um that's okay though i'm just gonna
occupy the center with my knights
target the weak squares and i don't
think my opponent's
crushing attack is really going anywhere
to be honest i can play queen g2 if i
once and get rid of this queen sort of
at any time however
i have more devious intentions we'll see
if my opponent
is able to stop them or not
more devious intentions than a queen g2
in the spot my opponent plays knight f6
and yeah maybe this is
sort of the only way to solve the
problems
so my devious intentions were to move
the bishop and play knight
g5 trapping my opponent's queen
but uh here perhaps if i take
the knight takes then the queen will
have the g4 square
that's okay though i think i'm gonna
play it anyways
um and am i gonna take this
i suppose i could i suppose i could take
this guy i'm just gonna play knight g5
i'm going to play for the clock
rather than the position here because i
think that's
the best strategy
oh wow okay that move
surprisingly has everything defended
and now i'm sort of lagging a little bit
but we
are keeping it all under control still
okay bring this over here play rookie
eight
get some trades going
and yeah lots of lag lots of lag but
that's okay
we're gonna get there anyways we're way
up on time
and somehow someway i won this game as
well
hopefully we don't have any close time
scrambles because then uh
i'm just gonna get destroyed but we win
we win this game
and move to three out of three
in the event looks like shalhada uh the
number two rated person in the event is
still playing
oh and shalhot is getting flagged
cornwallis
69 with the big upset here
defeating shalata and moving to a
perfect score i
suspect that will be our opponent in the
next round
and uh maybe i've made a bit of a death
wish there uh
asking for no close time scrambles
because cornwallis seems to know
what they're doing
all right here we go i'm gonna play the
carol again
and we get a king's indian uh attack
type of uh setup here i wonder if i know
who this person is there was someone at
the chess club today
uh telling me about a certain king's
indian attack
that was played uh very recently by one
fabiano caruana
and i wonder if this is the same person
rocking
the st louis cardinals avatar okay i'm
going to go
queen c8 and e6 here
and the reason for that is i want to
unpin my knight from all directions and
then
fight back on the dark squares this is a
pretty common
strategy when you have a fiancee
dark squared bishop you want to put your
pawns on light squares
and make this bishop sort of a
powerhouse so that's sort of what i'm
going for here
uh realistically though it's a blitz
game i'm just trying to keep my kings
safe
and keep the game rolling okay my bishop
gets pushed around a little bit
but my opponent's king is gonna find
itself being a little bit
airy in these positions and even if we
trade off all the rooks as we're doing
here
um this king can definitely come under
some fire especially
with opposite colored bishops as we have
here
that's why we see my opponent playing
this move king
to f1 i'm also going to improve my king
i'm considering this move
h5 to kick the opponent's bishop a
little bit back
and then i'm going to try to go after
some of these soft looking pawns over
here
on the queen side now that my opponent's
queen has left the file i'm definitely
looking to take on d1 to free up my own
queen
i'm now hitting two weak points uh e3 as
an invasion square and b2
okay my opponents continues playing
quickly
i'm going to go a5 to lock down this b4
square
and i'm honestly considering some very
brute force ideas here
very brute force ideas all right i am
going to go
queen c5 and just keep the game
flowing here i've got some ideas of b5
in this position maybe even
a4 to make some breaks maybe b4
is a better idea that's what i'm going
to go with again just keeping
keeping time with my opponent here not
playing too quickly
nor too slowly and my opponent offers a
big queen trade i'm going to have to
decline
going to have to decline that queen
trade
as i think it would be just a little bit
too
drawish if i were to decline okay i'll
continue to climb and go queen a4 i'm
playing with a little bit of fire
letting my opponents queen in but i
should be invading as well
and if we both invade i'm simply going
to have the safer king my king has all
this nice shelter
in front of it and my opponents is
looking
slightly barren got a barren king over
there
and not b-a-r-o-n b-a-r-r-e-n
i think spelling's hard uh okay
so my queen has invaded and now making
use
of the opposite colored bishops i am
able to very easily attack on the dark
squares here
and this is what i was hoping for all
along i just take over the dark squares
entirely and my opponents simply cannot
cover everything
and this is going to be checkmate in a
few
i'm hoping uh maybe it's not quite that
easy
my opponent can run out to the g4 square
here
but uh should be very tough to keep this
king alive
for too very long and
how are we going to do this how are we
going to do this everybody
i'm honestly not sure i'm going to start
with king h6 take away this g5 square
from my opponent
and we're going to go from there
this is one idea that's maybe not so
ridiculous but
i don't know if we have to get quite so
uh
quite so dramatic with it ah i found it
bishop e3 is a nasty nasty move here
queen takes f2 you i bet you think i'm
gonna take that queen back i bet that's
what you thought
i bet you thought i'm gonna take this
guy's queen he's gonna take me back and
it's gonna be into the game
little did you know g5 checkmate
and there you go hello to arch in the
chat
and so far so good for for me we're
successfully keeping ahead in the road
to 2000 tournament it would be so
embarrassing
if i were to not win this event as the
instructor of the class
a pretty good turnout here we've got 17
players in the event and sheilata the
second highest rated person
did stumble in a previous round here but
i think with a win here
they will likely be our next opponent so
what's going on
looks like white is winning a rook and
has some extra time on the clock this is
definitely
what you need to do
did i miss bishop e7 mate i missed
i missed bishop e7 mate well my mate was
cooler
okay i found the cool way to get to the
diagonal you know nothing about nothing
all right my mate was way cooler it was
way cooler i got to sacrifice my queen
come on
i'm pretty sure bishop e7 was me i think
i just missed it
i think i just missed that one it
happens sometimes we got the desired
results
life is good and the question is will
shelhada
get the desired result or will black
find some way
to uh to checkmate here
uh the good news for you tom is that i
don't often play e4 i'm more of a d4
player
but uh if we get paired maybe i'll i'll
try it it's been a while since i made
the nidorf videos i'm not confident that
i remember all my own lines that i
recommended
so you might be might be doing okay
and once again the position on the board
irrelevant when compared
to the number of seconds on the clock
shelhada
moves to three out of four
and we continue up against the number
two seed in the event now
shale hada and i'm unable
to play a move i'm pre-moving i'm
pre-moving my first move i did it
i pre-moved d4 not an easy task
on move one to uh to pre-move but we we
did it somehow
in my opponent's playing a sort of
clever move order here
to get into um
the slav i'm just gonna play knight c3
keep things simple
and now i actually play the exchange
slot but my opponent gets a very very
slightly
improved version of the exchange slot
against a couple lines including mine
so in most cases i would have played
bishop d3 last turn instead of this move
knight c3
but because of the move order i had to
play knight c3 instead this allowed my
opponent the extra
opportunity to put this bishop on f5 but
since bishop f5 was not played we have
simply transposed
just some slav knowledge for you there
some slav knowledge
bishop g4 and we're back in the main
line
back in the main line
bishop back over to g6 now is
rather interesting um
i'm just going to play quickly here on
the queen side my opponent chose to play
slowly in order to get rid of my bishop
but this came at the risk of falling a
bit behind in development
so i'm going to use my extra development
here to take over on this side of the
board
and see if i can force my opponent to
make some weaknesses
if my opponent hadn't wasted those two
tempi moves like
castled queen b6 and then rook c8 could
have been played
instead we're seeing this bishop take on
d6 to just remove the threat
and this is why perhaps you should wait
a little bit before
bringing this bishop all the way over to
uh the g6 square in this case though i'm
also wasting time
because this knight effectively hits my
rook if rook c2 there
i believe my opponent would have played
knight before attacking two pieces at
the same time very scary stuff
and now my opponent is coming after me
trying to
checkmate me on the king's side it looks
like
yeah this is not a fan not a plan i'm
entirely familiar with
but it looks fun enough for blitz i'm
actually going to take with the pawn
here
give my king this little hidey hole on
f2 if need be
i could have also taken with the
knight and maintained my pawns but i
think i'm actually
going to use this open age file to apply
a little bit of pressure
on my opponent now of course if ticks
i'll take with the knight
and all of a sudden my opponent's king
once again is looking
a little bit bare no time to castle
queen side and the queen side is
also not exactly safe with this open c
file
looming queen f6 now barely keeps it
together
[Music]
of course that move i was hovering would
hang a rook
so it's not ideal but now i need to find
a move
what to play here what to play
my opponent wants to castle what do i
want
i think i want to play knight h5 to
start and
figure out the rest from there while
queen h8
is bold um i'm gonna play a stupid move
am i gonna play stupid move i
i really like playing stupid moves but
maybe that one is a little too stupid
to be any good maybe that one's just a
little too stupid to be any good i'll
take a free pawn instead
i'll take the free pawn instead
um the chat room's making fun of me
again i sure hope i didn't miss anything
if i missed something that would be so
embarrassing
okay what are we doing here i think i
want this queen on f3 and then
my life makes a lot more sense i think
that's the answer here
put the queen on f3 and life starts
making more sense i can play moves like
this
now of course i do have to unpin my rook
first
i can take this guy push f6
and now uh now i should be winning
yeah queen h7 was the funniest move and
normally as a rule i always try to play
the funniest move
but sometimes the funniest move just
isn't isn't the best
okay that's a free rook and i think that
seals the deal maybe my opponent meant
rook f7
but at that point i think the game was
already pretty well enhanced there i'm
just going to push g5
g6 and that should do the trick
all right i think all the games are
pretty much
done in this round as well now we've got
nick still playing nick mike
and let's see how nick mike is doing
from germany
um looks like nick is down a couple
pawns in this end game also down
30 seconds never good to be down 30
seconds when you're also down the pawns
matt loves and plays the caro con two
things i thought
that i thought were impossible to do at
the same time i thought you know you can
either love the caro khan or you can
play the kero khan
but not both so good to see that uh matt
is out here breaking all the rules
good game shalash thank you for the game
that was an interesting idea you had
with
the king side push against the exchange
slot i'm not so sure
it was great but uh you know i didn't
love my position out of the opening so
maybe
there was something to it
yeah maybe there was something to it
all right we've got round six coming up
here we're on a perfect five out of five
so far
looks like breetak is on four out of
five so
one win here and uh
we might be might be back in the thick
of it and wow britax says
say hi to ryan daring for me ryan
is someone who i haven't seen in quite
some time he used to uh
work here at the chess club but moved
away to texas i wonder if i'm playing
ryan or if this
is someone else who's a friend of ryan's
unclear unclear
i'm gonna play the stupid way this time
and just play bishop f5
i get this nice juicy square on e4
and uh in return
you know my my pawns look a little silly
you missed this one when is the next one
unfortunately
marco this could potentially be uh
the very last road 2000
tournament i can't confirm for sure this
could be the last one
this could be the last one and that is
because
we are moving back to doing things in
person here at the chess club
and so our online programming is going
to slow down
perhaps just a little bit in the form of
tournaments
um no need to fear though because if
you're in the st louis area
there are plenty of events you can tend
how can you join the club if you can
well head on over to st louis
chessclub.org
and i think all the information you need
is gonna be posted
there if you're in the st louis area you
can also just come on down any day
first visit to the chess club totally
free so just come
check it out and uh
and see if you like it the last yeah not
the last road 2000 but perhaps
the last road 2000 tournament it's been
a lot of fun doing these
but uh you know all things
must move on i'm playing night a five
here to distract the knight from the
defense of the bishop
hoping i'm gonna be able to take and
then take back
and more than fancy trades i will have
fractured my opponent's pawns ever so
slightly
and with this uh fracture fracturing of
the pawns
it's less about the pawn on c5 being
weak although that is nice i mean it's
more about
activating this bishop along this
diagonal if i can just activate the
fiance bishop
then my position will be fantastic
my opponent now trying to stuff a knight
in my face and make me
uh eat my words about activating my
bishop and now i think i can rely
on the weakness in this on the c5 pawn
pretty hard while you live in israel
well then you can still keep up with
this
online um oh and something is going on
here
my phone my phone i'm being called
by grand master denis borosch should i
answer
i think maybe not i think maybe not but
that's okay
all right i'm going to head on over with
rook e4 now
and f takes e is the plan i'm just up
some material here
so things should be going all right
all right knight d4 is hitting my guy
i'm gonna take and see if we can
secure a victory here um
up some material in this rook end game
is enough to win
i think it probably should be my
opponent's king is not going to make it
too
far and in the meantime i can start
pushing this
just conglomeration of pawns
and that i have in the center of the
board
um so speaking of grandmaster dennis
borosh he's probably calling me
to figure out the details for his class
tonight his class of course coming up
right after my class i don't want to
miss that one
okay i'm going to go ahead and push
through here well my opponent doesn't
take i thought my opponent would take
in order to get this king to f4 but not
taking
is perhaps also interesting the idea i
believe is just to keep my pawns doubled
to make it harder for me to
push ooh but that's a fork that's a
nasty fork right there
and i believe i have won this game
all right just one round remains in the
tournament can i go seven out of seven i
think
with this victory i may have secured
first place thankfully so
uh don't get dethroned in this edition
of the roger 2000 tournament check and
win queen
are you missing something i don't know
what position you're talking about
maybe there was some free queen
somewhere but
uh i didn't see it in this case though
i'm just pushing pawns and winning the
game
alright um
how many games are left oh my gosh so
many games are left
so many games let's check back in on
alex here see how alex is doing
and alex turning the tables here has the
one with the shaky looking king
but also has the extra seconds in this
case
oh also black's king looks a little bit
shaky as well
um yeah simply rook takes b3 and alex
has this game well in hand
um wild position though absolutely crazy
absolutely craziness oh and that's
checkmate a nasty checkmate by alex
to secure the victory there against pb
diamond
what else is going on we've got shilata
still playing let's check back in
enchilada with 30 seconds enchilada has
been like the last game to finish in
almost every round here
i wonder what that's about just this guy
just plays
chess and gets interesting games
looks like a free queen though and this
game probably won't last too much longer
or the free queen could be missed we get
97 instead
and game continues okay knight takes f5
and uh still well in hand for white i
personally would have gone for the free
queen
but i missed mate and one earlier in
this event so you know i'm not one to
talk here
and we get resignation with 0.1 seconds
on the clock and impressive feat
by mike here resigning before the clock
can resign for him
and now we're down to just one game left
mendel 55
against dry ran and what do we got
we've got queens and mendel just
trying to not stalemate trying to stay
ahead on the clock
and will we see the stalemate no
we will see the checkmate with 0.1
seconds again again very impressive
stuff
ending games with 0.1 seconds on the
clock and with that
it is now round seven out of seven
oh and look who it is look who it is
so much better than you this is mike
cummer himself
uh throwing down the gauntlet here
trying to uh
trying to win my spot
as the road 2000 instructor and he's
just disrespecting me
oh my the disrespect launching the pawns
unbelievable unbelievable stuff gotta
stop those pawns before they get too far
and now i get to take over the center
and
get a nice free win get to crush them
with my extra central space here we go
oh my gosh isn't it great how much space
i have
you don't even have to do anything
special here you just you let the space
play the game
for you develop your pieces castle
you know what's what's the trouble there
is no trouble
all right i'm gonna play this move now
and uh see if we can get a quick
checkmate
from uh mike here i'll go ahead and take
this
and mike's in a tough spot that's a free
bishop thank you very much
oh and that's checkmate move 17
checkmate and mike
is destroyed tough game mike
tough game shouldn't have wasted all
that time
looks like i'm going to get first place
in this event but we've got plenty of
other games going on this looks like
it's going to be one of the most
interesting matches
bree tak enchilada two of the strongest
players in the event
um and we'll see what they can do we'll
see what they can do
looks like a pretty solid position for
both players here
uh britak taking over the the center
space a little bit against the pirates
um and in the meantime shia ladies
bishop on
b7 not my favorite piece in the world to
be honest
this looks like some of those funny roy
lopez positions where
why why is this bishop sitting over here
you know what i mean wouldn't this
square just be much much better for it
and trying to take advantage of that we
actually see bretock playing
knight h4 and f4 and this is where you
really feel the absence of this bishop
white is going after all of these light
squares that
otherwise wouldn't normally be quite as
weak
in return though it looks as though a
tactic was missed little bishop
takes h4 idea by shaylata winning a pawn
on e4
and okay that's not the end of the story
though we see g3 as the
rook was under attack maybe white could
have played knight takes d6
but i'm not one to talk i don't know how
to calculate uh
instead we get f takes e and d takes e
and it looks as though
shalata actually got the better of
things in that little tactical flurry
there
black simply has more pawns and now
after c5
the bishop will be joining the fray and
i see no reason why
black shouldn't be better white's king
also very open
looks like a tough game for bredock
all right let's move along then and
check out somebody we haven't seen
too much of who haven't we seen too much
of yet in this event
maybe dryran against nick mike nick mike
i think
definite long-term viewer of the stream
it's tough for me
to remember how the usernames match up
i'm not sure exactly who it is
but i remember seeing the name enough
that they are regular
and we've got some weird things
happening on c3 here
white uh not electing to castle this
game and black looking to put the hurt
on
uh due to that fact and wow i don't know
why black refrained from capturing this
pawn i definitely would have
now white is getting the free castles in
and uh will be able to
play a little bit more safely than
otherwise
okay queen g6 trying to increase some
pressure here
rook b1 attacks a bishop on b7 bishop d6
does not defend the piece that was
attacked
if i'm playing with white pieces i'm
taking the free bishop and
that is looking pretty tough for nick
mike as well
let's jump back to this game where
bretock is
still fighting we've again got this weak
white
king black with the extra pawn and
the safer king and more development in
the two bishops
and wait a second i didn't count the
pieces why does white have so many
pieces
why does white have so many pieces f5
attacks the knight the knight moves
king g7 and that's a free piece on e5
all right never mind
brie talk definitely the favorite in
this game you know
extra pawn and wheat king is only worth
so much uh
extra piece also going to be worth a lot
here
although perhaps actually you know the
tide is turning once again
and i'm starting to prefer uh starting
to prefer
a lot of position once again this pawn
on f4 is impossible to defend
and after this pawn falls you're gonna
see this queen weasel its way in
here let's see move like c5 come up and
together the piece is swarm and that's
simply checkmate and two
good game to breedhawk winning that free
piece but it wasn't enough
sometimes the weak king is just too
weak let's check back in on mike glo
gl gl gloudon's glaudumens
mike here up a queen but again eternally
down on the clock
cornwallis has proven to be the speedy
uh player
of the tournament uh and once again
using that speed here to try and win
down the queen and yeah turns out it's
going to be enough
extra seconds always worth extra queens
and that's the tournament that was the
final game i did manage
to win this one um going seven out of
seven
so my throne here as the road to 2000
teacher
is for the moment safe uh hopefully you
guys enjoyed i
believe everyone who played in the
tournament is actually entered into a
raffle it's going to be held after the
summerslam bash
on june 23rd and the winner of that is
going to get a free lesson
with our resident grandmaster speaking
of which that guy is dennis borosch and
he's going to be coming in
in just a few minutes to teach you guys
some chests so stay tuned it'll be right
here on the youtube channel
um and dennis borosch is going to be
talking
some chess all right as always thank you
guys so much for watching this is
uh these tournaments have always been a
blast it was a pleasure
to actually play in one rather than just
commentate hopefully you all enjoyed
and i will see you guys next time
goodbye